call me dude Z one thing I've always
wanted to do is a western okay I would
love to be in a western and like doozy
said there's currently a 0.07 chance
that I will win an Oscar that's I gotta
say that's a hard genre to win an Oscar
and now if I may go for it I'm going to
look up when unforgiving came that movie
that came out with Will Smith where he
was the doctor that cracked CTE for the
NFL do you remember that the Wild Wild
West
it wasn't that well I forget what it was
called
it was called The Wild Wild West it's
called like concussion or something or
it was called The Wild Wild West the
Western that uh Will Smith did yeah
there's some interesting stories it
wasn't that but he he came out with in
that movie he got nominated for an Oscar
I'm a western guy in the plains I got a
gun on me and I right take trains so
that movie